[Música]
[Aplausos]
yo nací
[Música]
qué
[Aplausos]
para nuestros problemas
y nosotros
[Música]
las de la ladera
a las próximas exposiciones
[Música]
i
yo
pero
[Aplausos]
ah
pues sí
en el año 2008
[Música]
[Aplausos]
a veces tienes
más
este grado
la parte más importante
6 millones ácidos grasos trabajosamente
arista delante de mí que sufran de este
entorno
[Música]
d
y esas
[Música]
la idea no es nada
y todos los esfuerzos todos esos meses
las dos nuevas salidas todas esas
frustraciones y días que tenemos
trabajando de forma intensa
y en 2012 lo teníamos claro
[Música]
la que se dejaba
jaja
esa diferencia
a todos
[Música]
si es importante que venimos haciendo
cosas con ella
[Música]
con matices de justicia
[Risas]
no estoy mal
cómo que no
[Música]
las ventas
y yo
algo
[Música]
piensa por qué
sí
[Música]
todas estas cosas del pasado
yo estaba en la juvenil de
investigadores que compartían que
estaban atrás
y
en este entorno pues
el que esté tratando de estar
[Música]
sugerencias
una de las más esperadas
y ahora bastante
pérez
de nosotros
[Música]
pero no
necesidad de partículas
lo importante
no sé si nos gente a la población a la
sociedad de esta estética
dios
es voluntario
así yo podría mostrar para transiciones
las familias que hacemos en el set
[Música]
pero aprendiendo
a ustedes chicos chicas ingeniar las
sociedades mirados no muchas veces
escolares con el apoyo a grandes
escolares
hablar de la ciencia
[Música]
a ellos
un hombre de verdad
aquí en este momento
d
transmitiendo las vidas
y esto fue un gran jardín
las transforma
de las personas
de actividad
en la que yo
[Música]
y es que la ciencia
apasiona
[Música]
porque es una forma que es la materia
como cómo se transforma
los hombres y ahora vamos
y esto los entiendo por qué
algo especial
nos cuesta dar respuesta cuando nos
enfrentamos a la
trabajo
[Música]
en este ejercicio lógico
si yo lo hacía
y las agujas
y no me dejan
pero no existe
s
una roja
[Música]
este es uno más
tuvo de llorar
[Música]
tenga esa capacidad
una vez
[Música]
es como es
esa que nos permite compartir y
conectarlas a tareas
y nuestro mundo se transforma
en nuestros ojos
[Música]
[Aplausos]